hey everybody welcome back to the
GameSpot stage I'm joined by John and
Matt how you doing guys cam what's up
buddy oh man it's really nice to have
you guys on stage so we can an honor and
a privilege oh now you go it now are you
perfect
I'm so excited already learn to come
talk to you a week Thursday end of the
day I'm not tired at all let's do this
let's do this all right so what are we
looking at you got lots of toys I'm
looking at don't you recognize these
guys you might have for starters we got
cats in Canada here and a wolf man or
something yeah yes now of course because
because it's your second game right this
is Disney infinity Marvel superheroes
open parentheses 2.0 edition close
parentheses they're important presence
the lawyers want me anyway yeah so uh
about a month ago we announced that
we're coming out with Disney Marvel
superheroes yep we announced that The
Avengers were a big part of it who said
we got more place that's more characters
coming and so today at e3 actually two
days ago at e3 he'll push that yeah we
we announced that Spidey is coming and
bringing his buddies and we're showing
the the spider-man playset as well as
the Avengers yeah so Matt's playing it
right now just like all the other place
that's from the first version of
infinity it's about a four to six hour
experience ten hours for the
completionist and this particular story
it's about Mysterio and Green Goblin
they can team up in the kidnap venom and
then they begin cloning symbiotes out of
them who freaks out escapes but not in
time for them to start unleashing a
sybian scourge on Manhattan so septa
Spidey iron this director Nick Fury
Nova and venom put a stop to the
invasion but that's a challenge for you
guys for you players out there can you
do it
excellent so we've all just got these
new and Marvel Avengers like superheroes
figures
yeah I'm spider-man is the latest one
yeah so can we like swap him out any
time any moment or like how does he
interplay with all the other guys ok so
inside the game yes at any point you can
pull a character out put another
character down you can totally do that
one thing though in the first version of
infinity yeah we were doing all true to
property experiences so we weren't
letting you take a character like Buzz
Lightyear for example and bring them in
the Pirates of the Caribbean world
that's what our toy box mode was all
about however in the Marvel World
characters often do cross over the comic
books and in different anime series and
stuff like that so the team at Avalanche
software is created Disney infinity
works really really closely with Brian
Michael Bendis and Joe Quesada Brian
Michael Bendis it's like you know the
the modern day you know Godfather of
Marvel comic book writing and so anyway
our team wrote the script and Brian came
in and actually helped integrate what
we're calling crossover stories so
inside of the ultimate spider-man
playset there are characters from other
Marvel franchises that are being
integrated into infinity 2.0 okay such
as Iron Man which we'll announce today
you can actually put him down yeah and
then you can bring Iron Man in there now
not every character crosses over Kim
only certain characters do yep but the
the what we wanted to do was actually
right into the story why that character
is appearing in that world
alright so iron man has exclusive
content and missions that explains why
he's coming to fight alongside Spidey in
the game to help complete the game so
whenever you put whatever you put on a
game ultimately he says alright I need
to fill in this bit of story here this
wire mines here and any for any comes
yeah and then you do different missions
and stuff with him and by the way I
don't know if you saw like the web
slinging that we have inside of you know
it's like in terms of characters and
mechanics and everything we're trying to
do we're really trying to go deep to
make sure every one of these superheroes
feels totally yes you've always thought
that with superheroes because you know
fans of the Marvel Spidey maybe more
than anyone really really hard time hard
fans you never get that level of detail
you know just remember this is this
fight about experience is one yeah well
I mean did you play and so we think that
some of the best web swing that's been
out there I was Treyarch spider-man 2
video game we're back on I think it's
PlayStation 2 yes yeah we all got in
that one super super close in terms of
wine again
our web swinging you know feeling just
as good to be just as accessible so
we've got that but with the character
like Iron Man that Matt's got on screen
right now he's a flier character and
with our whole new skills and attributes
system we have in the game you can
actually level up your characters in
different ways to do different things so
if you actually want to really focus on
all the web swinging and web slinging
that Spidey has you can do that with
Iron Man if you want to unlock you know
some more special abilities new moves
stuff like that can do that as well
now that not only this happens with the
Marvel characters but it also happens
with all the new Disney characters that
we're bringing to the platform this year
cool and last but not least sorry go
ahead on oh you can ask well I just kept
walking I like I like all right I wasn't
thrilled it's the Italian in here so I
will continue to talk and move my hands
and sweat from my forehead well I fell
question for you one question you
mentioned already toy box mode and there
you go like that's why you can people
create their own can aspire to my stores
in there so what is torque what despite
about bringing plug loss mode
well spider-man inherently brings all of
his you know key abilities and moves and
things like that inside of the toy box
yeah we also have power de sand
different elements from spider-man's
playset that you can then put down and
decorate your toy box with okay we've
done a lot with the toy box this year I
mean what we notice in our like if I if
I talk real to you for a minute
we look at our bi date already we look
and study our data but we notice is that
our players are actually spending about
sixty percent of their time inside of
the toy box mode building creating
editing so we put a lot of focus on
making sure that that was much more
accessible this year we've integrated
what we're calling an auto creator
feature which is actually like
procedural generation so you can like
put down you know these little Builder
characters and they'll circuit like
creating capsules for you three houses
and all this different kind of stuff all
in an effort to make this so much more
accessible to players it's just you want
everyone to feel like a toy box master
artist so you've got the place that's
like you see here we've got the toy box
mode and tons more content that I
probably can't fit in in five minutes
right well let's let's show off more of
the gameplay because you're cruising
around so we should we bring Spider Man
back because he's there he's the star of
the show really
this weekend right the weekends not even
the weekend to have lost all Chakotay's
yes III half the week how do you like
the director fury figure Lily could you
want to we can bring in the camera on
him I'll try not to hold him by his head
he probably like that yeah and it's the
that's a pretty good samuel l.jackson
there I had modeling days er I think I
should be my career yeah here they go
there yeah he's pretty good actually
yeah and Sam actually does reprise his
role does the voice in the game yeah
yeah it's really yeah it was a blast to
work that's fantastic I thought some
reason I thought you were joking
I don't know why and I was like do I
just like someone that joke oh I thought
I thought you only spoke seriously when
we lent in I thought that ow
okay right here sorry about that Kim Sam
Jackson Sam Jackson surprised this role
fantastic there you go so let's show off
why would I want to see spider-man in
action so let's what else can he do the
heroes have figured out there's a way to
like slow them down so they can go in
and like actually figure out how to stop
Green Goblin or Mysterio the way they're
gonna do that so we're gonna borrow an
Oscorp scientist who's gonna help set up
a he's a pulse generator spider-man does
a kidnap he may be a menace it's bold
he's being bold for the situation okay
okay
so there's this guy right here boy you
guys were talking like I actually
unlocked the shield hello car oh good
for you whatever alright so we're gonna
start uh go pick up this guy real quick
okay okay and then once we get in we're
gonna take them to three separate shield
generators of course like when you get
to the first one oh hey I have a menace
I'm never gonna get a car with you in
real life that was terrible yeah I've
ridden with him before yeah crazy did
the car fly he crashes so many rides
I've been denied for the rest of your
future
I'm sorry actually web-swing with him
it's kind of cool how that works yeah
I'll give you that so here we go
hey watch great older there hold his
buck yeah not a kind of cradle the bug
yeah first someone he's been borrowed he
seems quite okay with the whole thing
just like he's not sure that he's all
right hey speaking of which though yeah
do that show that okay yeah look at that
show me a thing we'll get back okay
look it's great explain to the people
that are watching right all right guys
we're not Liza - yeah yeah okay okay
okay I'll explain it so right now we've
changed some of the circular power discs
where they're actually gonna be costume
swaps this particular one right here is
for spider-man and fans out there might
be able to guess which costume it
switches to Oh which one is it Matt I
don't know baby boom hey there it is
thought you knew and what's great about
that powered is because even if you'd
use it underneath the character that
isn't spider-man you're still going to
get a buck but you're gonna get the
added bonus if you have spider-man and
we're also showing off with several
others of these costume swaps at our
booth at e3 like Captain America's World
War two outfit which looks awesome so I
only got here net oh you oh I don't have
them here right now I waited teased it
man I can tease yeah so we yeah we've
got that we have but they also apply
these new costume changes apply to the
new Disney characters that we're
bringing in plus we've got costume
change this for the legacy Disney
characters as well which for fans of
infinity you know people like also so we
like our people stuff I was hearing
about happy bility like they're sharing
the kind of creations are making in toy
bugs tell me better my bad like if I
create an awesome I'm an awesome thing
yeah do I go by sharing and how much
should people do that
okay so we've completely overhauled our
user interface to slam around to make
sure that creating is generate content
and then being able to download that is
it's like right up and front but we now
have the ability to have fans vote up
and vote down whether their favorite toy
boxes we also have the ability now to
sort like for instance if you just went
and got
to figure and you're like hey what why
boxes are out there that are good or fun
for a character like Iron Man a flyer or
a character like Iron Fist or you know
you can actually sort that way we're
still going to continue featuring each
week you get a running contest and
featuring the coolest toy boxes that the
user the user community makes the one
thing it's super cool is that all of the
toy boxes from 1.0 that you've made will
work inside of 2.0 and so in the first
version of the game we were cloud
snoring all of our toy boxes with our
Disney ID system and since we're doing
this which is you know the guys that
Avalanche did is a huge pain the answer
them to do it but they managed to make
it work right what's cool is that for
players that have upgrade like from an
Xbox 360 to PlayStation 4 they see the
sign at their Disney ID and they can
actually pull down the toy box from 1.0
that they made fantastic
well John man it's been absolute
pleasure having you on stage Jam so we
go time for him afraid Oh creepy one I
uh I know all right
yeah where's the studio uh I don't know
I thought you guys are gonna supply the
all